I love me some Israel and some Palestine
and I'm the only one that has the balls
to say
it I'm the only one who has the balls to
say it I want everyone to thrive and
prosper
okay the New York Times has this article
they come out with this
article we all know the bombing campaign
uh in uh Gaza has been has been
insane and in the front page of the New
York times we have scope and quality of
Gaza tunnels all Israelis a network as
large as 450 miles at has over 5,000
shafts now okay okay that's a piece of
news and we get that Hamas has tunnels
but the tremendous bombing campaign the
insane loss of life and
dislocation uh of peoples and things
like
that and now that this is written you
got to folks you go to I mean just for a
little I I get it but have a little just
have one Gentile write the thing because
here's the who's written this article by
the way on when by the way everybody's
protesting I can barely get to my show
in DC because of these protests they're
in New York they're everywhere they're
in La they're in every major city
massive protest Biden poll numbers are
crashing they're calling him genocide
Joe it's a it's a nightmare for the
Democratic party especially among young
people scope and quality of Gaza tunnels
arewe Israelis now what's funny about
this headline is it the scope of the
bombing is awing many people too right
around the world that's also aing people
this article is written by Adam Goldman
Ronan Bergman
and gal klewitz it's like and then uh
Patrick Kingsley we throw in the Gen
guys I mean I understand but just in the
idea of
objectivity throw in uh uh uh Billy
O'Brien throw in uh Tommy ianucci in
there this article about the Hamas
tunnels was written by Tommy ianucci and
O'Brien instead of this is almost like
in Windy City Heat solstein bertz the
character of the agent whose name is
solstein bertz Windy City Heat he goes
God I got really solstein bertz [__]
me this is kind of the vibe of that a
little bit I'm just saying throw in some
little different throw in a uh Tommy
Perez Perez Lopez something something
little different they're going to
Halt construction permits in Beverly
Hills they're going to Halt them until
there's more affordable housing who's
the mayor of Beverly Hills this is the
mayor of Beverly Hills she's dressed
like money she's dressed like a she
looks like a $100 bill this is what she
should do she get out grab the mic and
go listen to me I'm Lily Lily boss the
mayor of Beverly Hills every night I
look at my
husband and tell him to get off his
phone and I tell him when I look deeply
into his eyes I say
husband farhod whatever his name is I
say listen to
me I want more lowincome residents in
Beverly Hills but it has to be done
perfectly and every night we discuss it
because he's a property developer ER and
every night we discuss how to do it how
we can do it properly for example here's
a thought Here's a thought look at what
Hamas has done with
tunnels 450 miles of tunnels I think the
New York Times
said are you telling me we cannot build
lowincome housing in
tunnels under Beverly Hills like Hamas
did
can we not do
that some people that are friends with
Hamas live in Beverly Hills in very big
homes can we ask those people how it's
done is it impossible that we can't
build underground tunnels for low-income
people that also have skylights where
they can
see is that a bad idea no no it's
not it's one of my many good and that's
what Lily should
say Lily should say that in tragedy
there is
opportunity in researching the Hamas
Terror Network after the tragic event of
October 7th me and my husband were
stunned at the
intricacy of the tunnel system we
believe that we can accomplish something
like that in Beverly Hills a fully
functioning Subterranean City for
lowincome residents that has all the
things that they need check cashing
places places where they fry
food tattoos that you can go get with
your
children all in a tunnel Network an
intricate tunnel Network dug underneath
Beverly
Hills it's not a bad idea not a bad
idea